Cuando pensamos en resistencia y tecnología es en realidad mucho más fácil.
Hoy, ustedes verán a otros oradores, ya lo sé,
que hablarán de cosas sorprendentes,
y por supuesto, con la tecnología nunca lo es.
Entonces, comparativamente hablando, es muy fácil ser resistente.
Si vemos lo que ha sucedido en Internet
con una última media docena de años tan increíble
que es difícil incluso encontrar la analogía correcta para ello.
Mucho de cómo decidimos, de cómo deberíamos reaccionar frente a las cosas
y de lo que se supone deberíamos esperar del futuro
depende de cómo agrupamos las cosas
y cómo las categorizamos.
Por ello pienso que una atractiva analogía al boom y caída
que recién experimentamos con Internet es la de una fiebre del oro.
Es fácil pensar en esta analogía como muy distinta
de algunas otras cosas que se pueda elegir.
En primer lugar, las dos son muy reales.
En 1849, en esa Fiebre del Oro, se extrajo oro por valor
de más de US$700 millones de California. Era muy real.
Internet también era muy real. Esta es una forma concreta para que los humanos
se comuniquen unos con otros. Es algo importante.
Un gran boom. Un gran boom. Un gran caída. Un gran caída.
Uno continúa y las dos cosas tienen mucho de bombo y platillo.
No tengo que recordarles de todo el bombo y platillo
relacionado con Internet, como GetRich.com.
Pero era lo mismo que con la Fiebre de Oro. "Oro. Oro. Oro."
Sesenta y ocho hombres ricos en el barco a vapor Portland. Pilas de metal amarillo.
Algunos tienen cinco mil. Muchos tienen más.
Algunos sacan $100.000 dolares cada uno.
La gente se entusiasmaba mucho cuando leían sobre ello en estos artículos.
Fue El Dorado de los Estados Unidos de América.
El descubrimiento de inagotables minas de oro en California.
Los paralelos entre la Fiebre del Oro y la Fiebre de Internet continúan cercanos.
Por ello, muchas personas dejaron lo que estaban haciendo.
Y lo que pasaba era -- y la Fiebre del Oro duró años.
En 1849, cuando la gente en la Costa Este empezó a recibir las noticias,
pensaron, "Ah, esto no es real."
Pero seguían oyendo de personas haciéndose ricas,
y en 1850 aún lo oyen. Y creen que no es real.
Hacia 1852, están pensando, "¿Acaso soy la persona más estupida en la Tierra
por no correr hacia California?" Y empiezan a decidir que lo son.
Por cierto, estos son asuntos comunitarios.
Las comunidades locales en la Costa Este se agrupaban y equipos completos
de diez o veinte personas cruzarían en caravana a través de Estados Unidos,
y formarían compañías.
Estos no eran tipicamente esfuerzos solitarios. Pero sin importar nada,
si eras un abogado o un banquero, sin importar tus destrezas,
la gente dejaba lo que estaba haciendo para ir a buscar oro.
Este tipo a la izquierda, el Dr. Richard Beverly Cole,
vivía en Filadelfia y tomó la ruta de Panamá.
Tomaban un barco hasta Panamá, cruzando el istmo,
y entonces tomaban otro barco hacia el Norte.
Este tipo, el Dr. Toland, fue en carromato hasta California.
Esto también tiene sus similitudes. Doctores dejando sus prácticas.
Ambos eran muy exitosos, un médico en un caso;
un cirujano en el otro.
Lo mismo ocurrio en Internet. Tenemos drkoop.com.
(Risas)
En la Fiebre del Oro, la gente literalmente saltaba de un barco a otro.
El puerto de San Franciso se atascó con hasta 600 barcos
porque los barcos atracaban y sus tripulaciones los abandonaban
para ir a buscar oro.
Entonces había literalmente 600 capitanes y 600 barcos.
Convirtieron los barcos en hoteles, porque no podían navegar a ninguna parte.
Tenias la fiebre punto com. Y tenias fiebre de oro.
Y ustedes vieron algunos de los excesos
que la fiebre punto com creó y lo mismo ocurrió.
El fuerte en San Francisco en esa época tenía cerca de 1.300 soldados.
La mitad de ellos desertaron para ir a buscar oro.
Y no dejaron que la otra mitad fuera a buscar a la primera mitad
porque temían que no regresarían
(Risas)
Y uno de los soldados escribió a casa, y puso esta frase:
"La lucha entre lo correcto y $6 dólares al mes
y lo incorrecto y $75 dólares al día es una lucha bastante severa."
Tenían un mal flujo de caja en la Fiebre del Oro. Uno muy malo.
Esto es de la Fiebre de Oro del Klondike. Esto es la huella White Pass.
Ellos cargaban sus mulas y sus caballos,
sin planearlo adecuadamente.
Y no sabían cómo de lejos tendrían que viajar,
y sobrecargaban los caballos con decenas y decenas de libras de cosas.
De hecho era tan malo que la mayoría de los caballos morían
antes que pudieran llegar a su destino.
Fue renombrada como la "Ruta del Caballo Muerto".
Y el Ministro del Interior canadiense escribió en aquel entonces:
"Miles de caballos de carga yacen muertos en el camino,
a veces en montones bajo los riscos,
con monturas de carga y paquetes, desde donde han caido,
a veces en masas enredadas, tapando los hoyos en el lodo
y aperando el único punto de apoyo para nuestros pobres animales de carga en marcha,
a veces, lamento decir, exhaustos, pero aún vivos,
algo que ignorábamos, hasta después de que los miserables infelices
se movían bajo los cascos de nuestra cabalgada.
Las calaveras sin ojos de animales de carga por doquier
daban cuenta de un sinnúmero de cuervos en el camino.
La inhumanidad que este camino ha sido testigo,
la desolación y sufrimiento que tantos han vivido
es inimaginable. Ciertamente no pueden ser descritos."
Y saben, sin el hedor que acompañó esa experiencia,
hemos tenido algo similar con Internet: pésimos cálculos sobre el ritmo del flujo de caja negativo.
Les mostraré uno de estos y lo recordarán.
Este anuncio se mostró durante el Super Bowl del año 2000.
(Video): Novia #1: Dijíste que tenías una gran oferta de invitaciones. Vendedor: Pero la tenemos.
Novia #2: ¿Entonces por qué tiene ella mi invitación?
Anunciante: Lo que puede ser poco para algunos ... Novia #3: Eres mío pequeñin.
Anunciante: Podría ser algo enorme para usted. Novio #1: ¿Es ella tu mujer?
Novio #2: No durante los 15 minutos siguientes. Anunciante: Después de todo, es tu día especial.
OurBeggining.com. La vida es un evento, anúncialo al mundo.
Jeff Bezos: Es muy difícil entender para qué sirve el aviso.
(Risas)
Pero en el Super Bowl del 2000 se gastaron tres millones y medio de dólares
para emitir ese anuncio.
Aún cuando, en ese entonces, sólo tenían ingresos anuales de un millón de dólares.
Ahora, aquí es dónde nuestra analogía con la Fiebre del Oro empieza a divergir,
y creo que lo hace severamente.
Y ello porque, en una fiebre de oro, cuanto termina, termina.
Aquí está este tipo: "Actualmente, hay tantos hombres en Dawson
que se sienten profundamente decepcionados.
Han efectuado un peligroso viaje de miles de millas, arriesgando su vida, salud y propiedades,
por meses ejerciendo los trabajos más arduos que un hombre puede ejercer
y a la par con expectativas elevadas al máximo
han alcanzado la deseada meta sólo para descubrir
el hecho de que no hay nada aquí para ellos."
Y ello era, obviamente, una historia muy común.
Porque cuando extraes la última pepita de oro --
y lo hicieron sumamente rápido. Es decir, si miran a la Fiebre del Oro de 1849 --
toda la región rivereña americana, en dos años --
cada piedra había sido revisada. Y después, sólo las grandes empresas
que usaban tecnologías mineras más sofisticadas
empezaron a extraer oro del lugar.
Entonces existe una mejor analogía que permite ser increíblemente optimista
y esa analogía es la industria eléctrica.
Y existen varias semejanzas entre Internet y la industria eléctrica.
Con la industria eléctrica, lo que de hecho existe --
una semejanza es que ambos son algo finas,
horizontales, capas habilitadoras que atraviesan varias industrias distintas.
No es una cosa específica.
Pero la electricidad también es sumamente amplia, entonces debes especializarla.
La electricidad, ustedes saben, puede usarse como un medio increíble para transmitir energía.
Es un medio increíble para coordinar,
de forma precisa, flujos de información.
Existe un montón de cosas interesantes sobre la electricidad.
Y la parte de la revolución eléctrica en la que me quiero enfocar
es una especia de edad de oro de los electrodomésticos.
La "aplicación asesina" que preparó al mundo para los electrodomésticos fue la bombilla.
Entonces la bombilla fue lo que cableó el mundo.
Y no estaban pensando en electrodomésticos cuando cablearon el mundo.
En lo que realmente estaban pensando --
no era en llevar la electricidad al hogar.
Era llevar la luz al hogar.
Pero lo que tuvieron fue electricidad. Tomó un largo tiempo.
Y como podrían esperar, ello implicó un tremendo gasto de capital.
Todas las calles tuvieron que abrirse.
Esto es el trabajo realizado en el bajo Manhattan
donde construyeron algunas de las primeras estaciones de generación eléctrica.
Y están rompiendo todas las calles.
La Compañía Eléctrica Edison, que luego pasaría a ser Edison General Electric,
que luego pasaría a ser General Electric,
pagó todo esta excavación de las calles. Fue increíblemente caro.
Pero ello no es -- no es la parte más similar a la Web.
Porque, recuerden, la Web se montó
sobre toda esta pesada infraestructura
que había sido instalada para las redes telefónicas de larga distancia.
Entonces todo el cableado y la pesada infraestructura --
Estoy volviendo, de alguna forma, a la explosión de la Web en 1994,
cuando crecía 2.300% al año.
¿Cómo es posible que creciera un 2.300% en 1994
cuando nadie realmente invertía en la Web?
Bueno, es porque toda la infraestructura pesada ya había sido instalada.
Entonces la bombilla requirió la instalación de la infraestructura pesada,
y luego aparecieron los electrodomésticos.
Y esto fue gigantesco. El primero fue el ventilador eléctrico --
este es un ventilador eléctrico de 1890.
Y los aparatos, la edad de oro de los electrodomésticos realmente duró
-- dependiendo de cómo se mida --
entre 40 y 60 años. Un largo tiempo.
Empezó aproximadamente en 1890. El ventilador eléctrico fue un éxito enorme.
La plancha eléctrica, también enorme.
A propósito, este fue el inicio del litigio por el asbesto.
(Risas)
Hay asbesto debajo de la manilla.
Esta es la primera aspiradora, la aspiradora Skinner de 1905
de la Compañía Hoover. Y esta pesaba 92 libras,
requería dos personas para operarla y costaba un cuarto del valor de un auto.
Por lo que no fue un éxito de ventas.
Era realmente un producto para innovadores
(Risas)
la aspiradora Skinner de 1905.
Pero tres años después, para 1908, ya pesaba 40 libras.
Ahora, no todas estas cosas eran altamente exitosas.
(Risas)
Esta es una prensa para corbatas eléctrica, que nunca enganchó con el público.
Me imagino que la gente decidió no arrugar sus corbatas.
Este tampoco atrapó al público:
el calentador y secador eléctrico para zapatos. Nunca fue un éxito de ventas.
Venía en unos seis colores distintos.
(Risas)
No sé por qué. Pero ya saben, pienso que
a veces no es el momento justo para un invento;
quizás es tiempo de darle otra oportunidad.
Así que pensé en que podríamos crear un anuncio del Super Bowl para esto.
Necesitaríamos el socio adecuado. Y realmente pensé --
(Risas)
pensé que realmente resultaría, el darle otra oportunidad.
Ahora, la tostadora fue un gran éxito
porque antes el pan se tostaba en fogatas,
y ello tomaba mucho tiempo y atención.
Quiero resaltar algo. Esto es -- ustedes saben lo que es.
Aún no se inventaba el enchufe eléctrico.
Entonces esto era -- recuerden que aún no cableaban los hogares para electricidad.
Los cableaban para iluminación. Entonces, tus aparatos se enchufaban.
Cada habitación normalmente tenía un portalámparas en el techo.
Y lo enchufarías en él.
De hecho, si han visto el carrusel del progreso en Disney World,
lo han visto. Aquí están los cables entrando al portalámparas.
Todos los aparatos se enchufan ahí. Y tenías que sacar la bombilla
si querías enchufar un aparato.
El producto siguiente que fue realmente un gran éxito fue la lavadora.
Ahora, este era un objeto que provocaba mucha envidia y deseo.
Todos querían tener una de estas lavadoras eléctricas.
A la izquiera, el agua con jabón,
Y este es el rotor -- el motor que gira.
Y lavaría tu ropa.
Esta es el agua de enjuague. Entonces sacarías tu ropa de aquí,
y la pondrías acá, y luego pasarías tu ropa por esta prensa eléctrica.
Y ello era un gran fenónemo.
Lo dejarías en la entrada de tu casa. Era algo caótico y molestoso.
Y la conectarías con un largo cable dentro de la casa
enchufándola a tu portalámparas.
(Risas)
Y ello de hecho es un punto importante de mi presentación,
porque aún no habían inventado el interruptor.
Ello vendría mucho después, el interruptor para los aparatos,
porque antes no tenía sentido.
Porque no querías que esta cosa ocupando tu portalámparas.
Entonces, saben, cuando terminabas de usarlo, lo desenroscabas.
Eso hacías, no la apagabas.
Y como dije, tampoco habían inventado aún el enchufe,
por lo que la lavadora era un aparato especialmente peligroso.
Y hay
cuando lo investigas, hay descripciones espantosas
de gente que tenía su pelo o ropa atascada en estos aparatos.
Y no podían tirar del cable
porque estaba enroscado al portalámparas dentro de la casa.
(Risas)
Y no existía el interruptor, entonces no había una buena solución.
Y ustedes pensarán que nuestros ancestros eran realmente estúpidos
por conectar cosas al portalámparas de esta forma.
Pero, saben, antes de que me extralimite en condenar a nuestros ancestros,
Me gustarías mostrarles: esta es mi sala de conferencias.
Si me preguntan, es un arreglo de parche completo.
En primer lugar, esto fue instalado al revés. Este portalámparas --
(Risas)
por lo que el cable se sale siempre, así que lo pegué con cinta adhesiva.
Esto se supone -- ni me dejen empezar. Pero no es el peor.
Así es lo que se ve bajo mi escritorio.
Tomé esta foto hace sólo un par de días.
Así que no hemos progresado mucho desde 1908.
(Risas)
Es realmente un desorden total.
Y, saben, creemos que esta mejorando,
pero ¿han tratado de instalar un router 802.11 personalmente?
(Risas)
Los reto a intentarlo. Es muy difícil.
Conozco Doctores en Ciencias Informáticas --
este proceso los ha hecho llorar desconsoladamente.
Y ello asumiendo que ya tienen DSL en su hogar.
Traten de conseguir la instalación de DSL en su hogar.
Los ingenieros que trabajan diariamente en ello no pueden conseguirlo.
Tiene que -- normalmente vienen tres veces.
Y un amigo mío me contaba una historia.
No sólo llegaban y tenían que esperar,
pero luego los ingenieros, cuando finalmente llegaban,
por tercera vez, tenían que llamar a alguien.
Y estaban muy felices cuando el tipo tenía un teléfono con manos libres
porque entonces tenían que esperar en línea por una hora
para que alguien les diera el código de acceso
luego de que llegaban a la casa.
Entonces no somos -- nosotros somos bastante desordenados.
A propósito, DSL es un parche.
Es decir, es un par de cobre trenzado que nunca fue diseñado
para el propósito con que se está utilizando.
Saben, es todo el asunto.
Somos muy, pero muy primitivos. Y ese sería el punto.
Porque, saben, la capacidad de recuperación -- si lo piensan
en los términos de la Fiebre del Oro, ahora estarán deprimidos
porque se habría acabado con la última pepita de oro ya no estaría.
Pero lo bueno es que, con la innovación, no hay una última pepita.
Cada nueva cosa crea dos nuevas preguntas y dos nuevas oportunidades.
Y si creen eso, entonces creen que dónde estamos --
esto es lo que creo: creo que ahora estamos en un parche increíble --
y ni siquiera he hablado sobre los interfaces de usuarios en la Web.
Pero hay tanto parche, tanta cosa terrible,
que estamos en la etapa de la lavadora Hurley de 1908 respecto de Internet.
Ahí estamos. Nuestro pelo no se atasca en ella,
pero ese es el nivel de primitivismo de dónde estamos.
Estamos en 1908.
Y si creen ello, entonces este tipo de cosas no les molesta. Esto es 1996:
"Todos los negativos se suman resultando en que la experiencia online que no vale la pena"
1998: "Amazon.frita." En 1999: "Amazon.fracaso."
Mi mamá odia esta foto.
(Risas)
Ella -- pero ya saben, si realmente creen que esto es inicio,
el mismo inicio, si creen que es la lavadora Hurley de 1908,
entonces son increíblemente optimistas. Y yo sí creo que es ahí en donde estamos.
Y realmente creo que hay más innovación por venir
que la ya ocurrida.
Y en 1917, Sears -- y quiero decirlo correctamente.
Este fue un anuncio que publicaron en 1917.
Dice: "Use su electricidad para más que luz."
Y creo que es ahí donde estamos.
Y estamos en una etapa sumamente temprana. Muchas gracias.